if approached friends my name is Vince
Buddha I'm an independent film producer
based out of Toronto Canada I'm the
producer of the future film called Crown
& Anchor which is open theaters as we
speak in select cities across North
America you can check out primer nectar
film comm for more info on that I'm
really excited to make this video today
I hope is used to some of you out there
some up-and-coming independent
filmmakers or if you're just that kid
that's yesterday film school I want to
sort of talk about or offer up some tips
that I've gathered along the way in the
trenches of independent filmmaking and
these are sort of things that you know
we don't really learn in school we don't
really that you only really learn when
you're out there and and making a film
happen and also you know I think that
there's not a whole lot of resources out
there for producers I think there's a
whole lot of resources for if you're a
director or a screenwriter if you're you
know if you need to learn about how to
create to build character or to for
story arc and screenwriting you know
technical things that you'll need to
know if your cinematographer or wanted
me to sit in Zagreb there really isn't a
whole lot of information for producers
and and so hopefully in some way this
will add to filling that void but first
I want to talk about foreign anchor
because I'm really excited about it my
team and I are really excited about it
and sort of out there in the world now
and kind
of doing you know really well with
audiences people are really responding
it to it well and we're incredibly
excited about that and grateful for it
Crowder tanker is an intense family
crime drama that takes a look at what
the effects are growing up in an
environment of addiction and abuse it's
a there are two things that flipped many
many families I'm sure that resonates
with a lot of you watching this we you
know there was there's a real focus on
family here and there's a real focus on
how you know that kind of environment
can either manifest the effects of it
can manifest itself in a way where you
sort of go out into the straight and
narrow but still are internally
suffering from some of your experiences
as a younger person or it affects you in
a way where you are externally you know
living out some of the same kind of
qualities of people in your past that
were addicts or those same sort of
abusive tendencies I preached it with as
produced by myself my co producers Mac
Wells and Michael Rowe who both of which
also are actors and play the lead
characters in the film
their names are James Downey and Danny
Power and films directed by very bravely
directed by Andrew Rowe who makes his
feature-length film debut as a director
after having had a really successful
career as a short film director so it's
truly independent in spirit we it's sort
of Nod to you know those independent
films that we loved from the 70s and the
90s where there was the the sole focus
was about creating a film that we loved
that we could stand behind that was
unwavering that despite you know a lack
of resources
we were never going to compromise the
dream we were never going to compromise
the quality story the the talents and
actors it was really always about doing
whatever it took to make a pretty
fantastic movie and I am biased of
course because I produced this film but
I can honestly say with full
authenticity that that is what we've
accomplished so what I want to talk
about today is five tips that I want to
offer up that hopefully can help you if
you're starting out in the industry if
you are you know just out of film school
and sort of wide-eyed and ambitious and
and and really really want to get into
this industry and get started these are
I guess my five tips on how to
successfully produce an independent film
and things that you need to successfully
produce in a film that they didn't teach
you in film school the first tip is
probably the most important one and is a
question that you've got to ask yourself
and before you even embark on this
enormous challenge of making unit and
film or before you even enter this
industry is got to ask yourself why do
you want to make a movie and if your
reason is anything other than you
absolutely love films and you absolutely
are excited at the idea of making a
movie then your intentions are all wrong
if you're in this because you want to
strike it rich or if you're in this
because you want to become famous you
know postings are entire aren't entirely
impossible but the likelihood is rare so
what's going to sustain you throughout
the process of making the film as I've
mentioned many times it's a huge
is an enormous undertaking it's it's
going to be something that's going to
completely consume your life so when you
are in the trenches and you are met up
against an enormous challenge or
something that seems like it's
impossible to resolve or you know when
you are missing out on a lot in your
life because you've got to be at home
working on something you know and no one
is even noticing that you're doing all
of that work because it's just you with
pen and paper or your laptop what is the
thing that is driving you and or how are
you going to stay self-motivated and the
only thing that is going to sustain you
is that you have an absolute passion for
this art form but equally as important
as that is that you have an absolute
passion and belief in the film that
you're making when I got the script for
prior Aymer it was unlike anything I've
ever read before and the thing that I
loved most about it was that it was a
script that seemed familiar to me in in
some ways that it would sort of was
similar in many ways to a lot of the
films that I just loved but it was very
uniquely his own film so it was an
opportunity for me to produce something
that really was an ode to the filmmaking
of generations past that I absolutely
loved and absorbed over the years there
was also a way to be part of something
that was unique and interesting and
exciting and felt like a real kind of
contribution to cinema so really really
ask yourself why you are doing this
because you really really need to be in
it because you absolutely love it
because it can be it's a difficult
journey at times it's a lonely journey
at times despite having a team you know
you're you're all sort of collectively
doing things to make this show happen
and sometime
that separator and a lot of times its
together well what is sustaining you and
so the only thing that can be sustaining
you is you being in it for the right
reasons and you being in it because you
have to say she a real kind of tangible
passion that you have in your life took
number two find your people and what I
mean by that isn't you know find you
know simple oh really really good team
you know find a really great production
designer or a hair-and-makeup
or a great director or editor
you know whatever it crew or a cast
member it may be that's obviously very
important you've got assemble in with a
great team of people that are talented
that you trust that you believe in that
will contribute a lot to the film that
you can sort of allow to bring the best
of themselves to the project what I mean
by find your people is find your people
people that you want to partner with
people that you want to embark on this
kind of journey with people that you
trust and that you respect you know that
could be a co-producer or that could be
a director or whoever a screenwriter but
that person or persons that you are
going to continue to produce projects
with you know the people that are by
your side are incredibly important
because you're gonna rely on them
they're gonna rely on you and apart from
that it's you know you're gonna you each
bring something to the project that the
other doesn't have or has you know I I'm
trying anchor we all had different skill
sets as producers that we brought to the
table so find people that have a skill
that you necessarily may not have or or
have skillsets that complement yours
that that are that you're both strong in
certain areas but find people that are
skillful that have an equal amount of
passion
determination as you do and have equal
belief in the project because you know
you can't do it alone and and it's such
a huge undertaking that you really need
support but it's also not even just
about the making of the film
you know making the movie is is
difficult but it's also a lot of fun and
you want to make it with people that
even have fun with you know you want to
make it with someone that you at the end
of a 14-hour shoot day you still choose
to hang out with them and have a drink
or that you think you really have a
blast with going on
traveling for festival tour and film
festivals were people that you ideally
outside of working our project like this
would choose to be friends with you know
people that want you to be as successful
as they are that you're completing back
that they want you to gain as much out
of this as as them that you're all sort
of in it together and you know when
there are huge victories you're
celebrating in a really fun and exciting
way and then when you're down and out
you you know you're both in a position
where operating still from a position of
not getting up you know you just got to
find those people that you completely
click with in in terms of how you
perceive making a film how far you were
willing to go that is incredibly
important because again you can't do it
alone and you shouldn't even try to do
it alone it's it's too much of an
undertaking
so find there were people it's you're
probably important tip number three is
reframing the word no because no is not
an option I can't tell you how often you
now it's just a part of of this whole
process you know it's in a lot of ways
making a film is a risk and you're going
to encounter that word in every single
step along the way from pre-production
to production to post to all of it
you're going to in the pre-production
stage be told that you know your script
is too long or your script is doesn't
fit this demographic read your script
won't be sold but your script well
whatever in production you're you know
you're gonna have talent that won't
accept an offer because it's a it's an
independent film with a low budget and
you know you're going to find crew that
will say no you'll find vendors that
won't cut you a deal and you'll you'll
be met with so many knows throughout the
process that it's just gotta be
something that you've got to accept and
simple mean you gotta get used to so
you're gonna have a thick skin because
notice not an option so you've got to
reframe that work now and you've got to
reframe it to mean not for you know for
you but yes for someone else that is
equally as good or equally as talented
or equally as will have an equal
contribution to the film know might be
you know know from this sales agent or
this distributor but it means that it's
just not for you if you don't believe in
that if they don't believe in that film
then then they're not the sales agent
that you want or distributor that you
want anyway so you go after the right
person you find that right person no
could mean you know this location won't
be available and so you've gotta make it
work and you've got to find something
that will be as equally as equally the
right fit for or whatever senior
shooting know will be they're constantly
Constantino but reframe that so that it
doesn't you know feel like completely
compounded on one no stack on top of the
other because that will happen it's
inevitable but really if you look at the
word in from a different perspective and
you change it to just somewhere else or
yes somewhere else then it'll never be
an option to give up
so reframe of the word no because you
will hear it a lot tip number four is
identifying your resources this is
incredibly important and what I mean by
that isn't you know understanding what
your budget point is because obviously
you know how much one you've got to make
the film but separate from that it's
identifying a list of resources that you
can access that will add value to the
film the nature of making an independent
film is that you probably don't have a
whole lot of money but that shouldn't
discourage you and you should never you
come from a place of you know settling
because you want to make a high-quality
film you know what we achieved with
primer maker is something I'm incredibly
proud of because the film in terms of
quality in terms of not just only a
picture quality and sound quality but
story and and the talent that we were
able to get in the actors and actresses
that we have is is all combined creates
a film that I think stands up against
every major Hollywood picture in tears
right now have you heard about all the
drugs going on I have now back in the
day your father and I would handle this
and if he was here now maybe we'd still
endless but he's not that's on you
Oh whoever says you gotta handle this
but we certainly do not have the same
amount of money that they did and so
what we did was we we found ways to
maximize the amount of money that we had
to ensure that most of it went to scream
and went to the movie so create a list
of resources that you've had and this
can be you know opportunities that you
have with family and friends and maybe
you know it's colleagues in the industry
that all Angelo camera or will lend you
lighting gear or you know whatever it
might be look into your network look
into your family and friends and see how
they can help out and not just you but
your colleagues we are carmaker a
perfect example of this is our cool
producer and star Matt Wells is in Las
provided the catering and they would
come to set every day and and with some
cooked meals for our entire cast and
crew and it was kind of wonderful it was
you know great home-cooked meal while
you're you know on set for a long shoot
day but what we were able to achieve
there and the opportunity was that we
could save the money that we would have
spent for catering and in some instances
you know catering is expensive
it could mean an extra sheet day on
independent film which really really
helps your director and and generally we
also had incredible opportunities in in
locations you know people were generous
to us know there's just so much that are
also out there and there are so many
people that really do want to help you
out if they identify on you your
ambition and your excitement for
something that kind of stuff is
contagious and people want to be a part
of it so identify your resources and
don't be afraid to go after them because
people really really do want to
if they can the fifth and final tip
seems like an obvious one but it is one
that I really want to mention and it is
get experience do not try to embark on
producing an independent film until you
feel like you've got the experience and
the wherewithal to be able to undertake
such a huge responsibility
I didn't produce my first independent
film until I had worked in production in
various capacities both the television
and film for about ten years
I sort of came up the ranks and became a
producer and what that does for you in
working in different capacities in
production is sort of my only broadens
your network of people and people and
connections and people that you know in
the industry that you can rely on that
you can that can lend a hand to you or
be a support but what it does is it just
really makes you all of that experience
makes you a better producer if your your
main job as a producer is to be at the
helm of it you are in a leadership
position and a really important part of
being a leader is being there to support
system for your crew for the people that
you're hiring and you can't really in an
independent production provide support
to people if you don't know what their
job is so when you're out there in the
field you know ask questions take
different jobs whether it's in the art
department or as a PA or as you know as
a camera system you know do as much of
that work as you can do because it get
it broadens your sense of production it
gives you a real kind of bird's-eye view
of what everyone does and it gives you
an opportunity to ask questions to
different people
and get a real solid sense of what it
takes
across all departments to produce a film
and when you're making an independent
film
you obviously are restrained by your
budget point so there are other ways if
you're not paying your crew as much as
you normally would but they're you know
on board because they just love the
movie and they love independent films or
they want to get the credit or they want
to take the next step in their career
you there's a lot of other ways that you
could support them and make them feel of
value and if you really truly understand
the nitty gritty of what they do what
their job is you were better equipped in
doing that so experience is absolutely
essential it's important it makes you a
better producer Meister better leader it
makes you more confident and and is it
goes without saying but is incredibly
incredibly important Thank You film
courage fans for watching I hope this
was of service to you I hopefully maybe
shed some light on some new ideas maybe
I reaffirmed some old ones I don't know
but hopefully it was beneficial to you
and it talked something about the crazy
world independent filmmaking big thank
you to film courage for inviting us
Alana for supporting broadening core so
much not only with this video but with
my colleague Matt well is this video
talking about the DIY spirit of the
process of making this film which you
guys should check out you know our
trailers online I hope you know check it
out we go to Crown and Anchor film calm
to find out about the a triple release
and follow us on social all of those you
know crazy internet things but we are
excited and thank you for watching and
we hope you'll join us along the crazy
ride of this independent film